BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ARE BEING POURED BACK INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
THE STOCK MARKET HAS ADDED MORE
THAN EIGHT IN DOLLARS IN NEW
WEALTH.
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS ARE AT A 45
YEAR LOW WHICH IS SOMETHING
AFTER YEARS OF STAGNATION.
THE UNITED STATES IS ONCE AGAIN
EXPERIENCING STRONG ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
THE STOCK MARKET IS SMASHING ONE
RECORD AFTER ANOTHER.
>> THE STOCK MARKET IS UP SINCEM
>> THE STOCK MARKET IS UP SINCEY
ELECTION ALMOST 50%.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT TALKS
ABOUT THE STOCK MARKET A LOT.
HE DID NOT TALK ABOUT IT IN THE
SPEECH TODAY.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING ON THE SCREEN, THE STOCK
MARKET DROPPED ALMOST 1600
POINTS BEFORE REGAINING AND
FINISHING AT ABOUT ALMOST 1200
POINTS DOWN ON THE DOW.
THERE YOU SEE THE REST OF THE
MARKETS.
AS THE PRESIDENT NOTES AND THE
WHITE HOUSE PUT OUT LATE THIS
AFTERNOON, SINCE THE ELECTION,
THE DOW SPECIFICALLY HAS SEEN A
MAJOR INCREASE AND OBVIOUSLY
TODAY YOU SEE THE TOP OF THE
MOUNTAIN FALL OFF AND MANY WILL
SAY THIS WON'T BE THE LAST TIME
IN A VOLATILE SITUATION.
TODAY WAS THE SINGLE BIGGEST
ONE-DAY POINT DROP EVER BUT NOT
THE SINGLE BIGGEST PERCENTAGE
DROP IN THE MARKETS.
WHAT ABOUT ALL OF THIS?
LET'S BRING THE PANEL.
GUY BENSON, POLITICAL EDITOR AT
TownHall.com.
POLITICS AND KIMBERLY STRESSFUL,
MEMBER OF THE EDITORIAL BOARD OF
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
KIMBERLY, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS
ON A MARKET DATE LIKENESS
THAT OBVIOUSLY JARS A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THE MARKETS.
>> I THINK THE IMPORTANT THING
TO REMEMBER IS THAT THE ECONOMY
HAS NOT MATERIALLY CHANGED FROM
FRIDAY UNTIL MONDAY.
ANY REASON TO PANIC.
MORE LIKELY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
TALKING THAT DUMB MARKET WITH
POTENTIALLY LITTLE OVERVALUED
AND DO FOR CORRECTION.
LAST WEEK ALSO IS AWESOME RISING
BOND YIELDS.
THAT MAKES PEOPLE THINK
INFLATION, HIGHER INTEREST RATES
MAKES THE STOCK MARKET LOOK A
LITTLE LESS ATTRACTIVE.
SOME OF IT MIGHT'VE BEEN THE
MACHINES TAKING OVER.
AT A CERTAIN POINT WHEN THE
COULD HAVE EXACERBATED IT.
I THINK THE IMPORTANT POINT IS
THAT THE ECONOMY ITSELF IS STILL
VERY STRONG.
MARKET AS AN INDICATOR OF THE
HEALTH.
>> Bret:
OFTEN TRY TO STAY AWAY FROM
USING THE MARKET BECAUSE OF JUST
THIS REASON.
THAT SAID, IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT
THAT SOMETIMES THE INCREASE OF
CONFIDENCE IN AN ECONOMY CAN
FAR AS INTEREST RATES.
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND I AGREE
COMPLETELY WITH THE POINT THAT
KIMBERLY MADE.
YOU LIVE BY THE SWORD, YOU DIE
BY THE SWORD.
YOU PUT IT OUT THERE IS THE
SINGLE GREATEST INDICATOR OF
YOUR ECONOMIC PROWESS, THEN WHEN
YOU TAKE A HIT, THE STOCK MARKET
TAKES A HIT, YOU HAVE TO ANSWER
TOO.
IS IT GOING TO CHANGE THE
POLITICAL DYNAMIC HEADING INTO
THE MIDTERM YEAR AT ALL?
PROBABLY NOT.
I DO THINK THE ECONOMY IS GOING
TO BE THE SINGLE BIGGEST
CATALYST OF WHAT HAPPENS
POLITICALLY IN THE MIDTERMS
MOVING FORWARD.
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE FOUGHT
ON THIS GROUND AND THUS WE
CONTINUE TO SEE MANY MORE DAYS
LIKE THIS ONE.
>> Bret: GUY, IF THAT IS TRUE,
AND WHAT MO IS SAYING.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING FOR
ALL THE WORKERS WHO HAVE $1,000
CHECKS OR THE WORKERS WHO SEE
INCREASE IN THEIR PAYCHECKS AS
OF THIS MONTH, THAT'S CHANGING
THE DYNAMIC.
>> IT IS CHANGING THE DYNAMIC
AND I THINK THE REPUBLICANS
SHOULD BE HAMMERING AT THIS
EVERY DAY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TAKEN A
STRANGE APPROACH TO THIS GOOD
NEWS FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
FOR MILLIONS OF AMERICAN
WORKERS.
THEY ARE DEMEANING IN MANY CASES
THE CRUMBS THAT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING IN THE FORM OF BONUSES
AND ENHANCED BENEFITS, 401(K)
MATCHES, EXPANDED OPERATIONS,
HAD ARGUED HYSTERICALLY IN MANY
CASES WOULD NEVER MATERIALIZE
UNDER A BEER THERE -- UNDER A
BILL THAT WAS.
FOR DEMOCRATS TO TRY TO QUICKLY
PIVOT FROM THIS IS A TERRIBLE
BILL THAT WILL HURT
WORKING-CLASS AND MIDDLE-CLASS
PEOPLE TO THE GOOD NEWS FOR
PEOPLE ISN'T GOOD ENOUGH NEWS,
IT'S JUST CRUMBS AND THEY NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THEY SHOULDN'T GET
MAKE RHETORICALLY.
>> I THINK DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY
HAVE PLENTY OF ROOM HERE TO GO
AFTER THIS TAX LAW.
I AGREE WITH YOU, TRIVIALIZING
THERE'S PLENTY OF DATA OUT THERE
IN PLENTY OF ANECDOTES.
THE PRESIDENT IS FOND OF PUTTING
THERE'S PLENTY OF ANECDOTES OF
LAYOFFS, CORPORATIONS THAT TOOK
THE TAX WINDFALL, CLOSING DOWN
FACTORIES, LAYING WORKERS OFF.
AND $9 BILLION HAVE BEEN
INVESTED IN CORPORATE STOCK
BUYBACKS.
FOR DEMOCRATS TO BE ABLE TO
POINT OUT THE GROWING DISPARITY
THERE, THE CONSEQUENCE OF
PEOPLE, CEOs LAYING WORKERS
OFF IN ORDER TO LINE THEIR OWN
POCKETS IS A MUCH I THINK MORE
POTENT STRATEGY FOR THEM TO HAVE
THIS FIGHT THEN TRIVIALIZING
THOUSAND DOLLAR BONUSES.
>> Bret: IF THAT WAS ACCURATE
ACROSS THE BOARD, I THINK YOU
WOULDN'T SEE SOME OF THE POLLS
WHO ARE SEEING.
MONMOUTH HAS A NEW POLL OUT OF
THE QUESTION IS YOUR VIEW OF THE
TAX REFORM PLAN.
YOU LOOK AT THE POLL NOW AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT IT WAS IN
DECEMBER OF 2017 AND THE
DISAPPROVAL HAS BEEN ERASED AND
IT'S ESSENTIALLY APPROVE,
DISAPPROVE.
IT MATCHES ALMOST EVERY POLL.
REPUBLICANS.
IT'S DOWN TO TWO POINTS.
>> THIS IS THE BEST THING THE
REPUBLICANS COULD HAVE DONE.
THIS WAS THE BIGGEST COMPLAINT
ABOUT THE OBAMA ECONOMY IS THAT
INSPIRATION.
THERE WAS NOT A LOT OF GOOD
NEWS.
IT BUMPED ALONG.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE AN
ANECDOTE HERE OR THERE OF SOME
SPELL.
THIS IS WHY THE PRESIDENT HAS SO
MUCH HE COULD BE TALKING ABOUT,
NOT THE STOCK MARKET.
EVEN THOUGH STOCK MARKET --
PEOPLE DON'T TEND TO FEEL IT
IMMEDIATELY.
YES, THEY LIKE TO SEE THEIR
401(K) GOING UP, 529 FOR THEIR
KIDS.
IT'S ALWAYS SOMETHING IN THE
FUTURE.
MOSTLY IN THE FUTURE.
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT IS THE
DAY-TO-DAY PAYCHECK.
THE FUNDAMENTALS ARE SO STRONG
AND GETTING STRONGER AND WE ARE
ONLY A MONTH INTO THIS.
WE ARE NOT EVEN BEGINNING TO YET
SEE SOME EXPANSION THE DIFFERENT
COMPANIES HAVE PROMISED IN
INVESTMENTS THEY ARE GOING TO
MAKE.
THOSE OTHER THINGS REPUBLICANS,